comment ça va vous allez bien
aujourd'hui en cette fin d'année
j'espère que vous allez bien moi ça va
plutôt pas mal alors aujourd'hui je vous
près d'un smartphone dont je vous ai
déjà parlé il ya un petit moment
je voulais présenter et je n'ai pas
encore fait le test
on va donc aujourd'hui se parler de ce
smartphone là c'est un smartphone de
samsung c'est le samsung galaxy s 20-f
que c'est le modèle 5 g il existe une
version 4g il existe une version 5 g il
ya une vraie différence entre les deux
modèles qui est quand même assez
significative
je vais vous la détailler dans quelques
instants mais c'est aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui réalise en partenariat avec
bharti et samsung
merci à vous de sponsoriser cette vidéo
est de soutenir la chaîne il est donc
l'heure vous donner mon retour sur
samsung galaxy s 20 f e le samsung
galaxy s varie feu s'était petit frère
du samsung galaxy s d'un jeu pas si vous
en souvenez début 2020 il y avait trois
nouveaux smartphones dans la gamme ss20
et se vendent plus et s20 ultra ici ce
smartphone gas inscrit dans l'adn du s
bahn qui est un excellent smartphone
néanmoins pour tirer un prix beaucoup
plus bas
il a pas eu forcément faire des
concessions on va regarder quelles sont
ces concessions va regarder si ce
smartphone est intéressant si je peux
vous le recommander on va pas trop faire
petit or a pas trop gardé de suspense
bien évidemment c'est un smartphone que
je vous recommande d'ailleurs s'il vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien en maths
dans la description c'est un excellent
smartphone néanmoins est-ce qu'il est
fait pour vous ça c'est une autre
question
ce qui est super interpellons avec ce
smartphone c'est le nom et ça je voulais
déjà dit cff pour fans et des chiens et
non des sur un smartphone qui est dédié
aux fans de la gamme s la gamme s c'est
le très haut de gamme chez samsung pas
de concessions samsung est notamment
connu pour avoir de super dalle pour
être très bon au niveau de la photo et
ce samsung galaxy s 20 et feu ne déroge
pas à la règle
le samsung galaxy s vaille feu est un
smartphone qui est vachement cool c'est
un smartphone qui est coloré c'est un
smartphone qui est ciblé jeunes sans
smartphone qui est élégant qui a une
excellente prise en main fait le tour
très facilement vous le tenez il un peu
allongé certes mais j'aime beaucoup la
prise en main qu'on va voir ici avec ce
produit
ici j'ai la couleur bleue il existe en
la vendant vert en rouge en orange et en
blanc vous devriez donc pouvoir trouver
votre bonheur
mais le point le plus intéressant se
trouve de l'autre côté puisqu'ils si
vous avez un écran un très très bel
écran infiniti aux 6,5 pouces ce qui
diffère du samsung galaxy ace va un peu
standard c'est que vous avez un écran
plat ici rien d'incurver alors ce qu'ils
n'aimeront pas les écrans km ont
vraiment leur bonheur ici c'est un peu
différent
ça vous fait ressortir un peu
effectivement les bords sur le côté il
malgré tout j'aime beaucoup cette
proposition un autre compromis a été
fait c'est qu'effectivement on va pas
retrouver de quad hd + et du foulage
et 2400 par 1080 ça fonctionnera
parfaitement bien ici par contre on a
une très belle dalle super amoled et
surtout un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
vous pouvez donc faire le choix d'être
uniquement sur du 120 hertz tout le
temps en permanence ou alors de 60 hertz
le 120 hertz consommera davantage au
niveau de votre batterie mais par contre
vous apportera plus de fluidité pour
toutes les expériences de gaming et
c'est notamment ce qu'on vient chercher
ici sur ce smartphone donc ça j'aime
beaucoup les faits un peu pervers au
niveau des hauts parleurs c'est que vous
avez ici un haut parleur mono qui est
planqué juste en dessous est le deuxième
haut parleurs et bien c'est votre haut
parleurs qui vous servira pour passer
beaucoup de filles et vos appels on l'a
donc pas certain déséquilibre entre le
son qui va sortir de ce côté là qui va
plus partir dans cette direction et le
son là qui sort un petit peu plus face à
vous cela vient apporter néanmoins à
l'immersion c'est quand même plutôt
agréable
on va avoir plus de puissance à droite
qu'à gauche c'est un peu standard sur
les smartphones aujourd'hui
néanmoins c'est très bien d'avoir un son
stéréo d'un point de vue général au
niveau du multimédia c'est pour moi un
excellent smartphone le format est
vraiment très très bon l'écran super
bonne qualité l'audio et immersif et ça
reste vraiment très cohérent par rapport
à ce qu'on peut retrouver sur l'offre
globale des smartphones à ce prix là il
ya un autre usage qui est extrêmement
important qui se développe de plus en
plus c'est le gaming c'est un marché qui
est extrêmement intéressant pour toutes
les marques et samsung ici cherche aussi
à faire l'oeil aux joueurs sur
smartphone
c'est là où ça veut dire très
intéressant parce que vous avez deux
versions vous avez une version 4g une
version 5 g vous n'allez pas avoir le
même processeur si vous êtes sur la
version 4g ou la version 5 g si vous
voulez le meilleur processeur c'est
clair il faut aller sur la version 5 g
parce que vous allez retrouver l'un des
derniers processeurs les plus haut de
gamme de qualcomm
c'est le snapdragon 865 c'est le modèle
qui était présentée fin 2019 très
récemment qualcomm nous a présenté le
stand ragon 888 mais il équipera les
smartphones de 2021 pour l'instant le
865 reste le processeur le plus puissant
sur smartphone et sur la version 4g vous
avez un exynos 1990 les 1990 sera très
bon on reste dans le très haut de gamme
c'est le processeur qui équipe les
samsung galaxy s 20 donc il fera
parfaitement bien la faire mais il ya
une différence pour les jeux qui seront
les plus gourmands les plus pointilleux
ceux qui demanderont le plus d'exigence
il ira moins loin que le stand ragon 865
il sera aussi moins bon niveau de
l'autonomie
là où le stand ragondins 865 sera mieux
optimisé d'une façon globale pour la
gestion de vos smartphones et notamment
au niveau de l'autonomie l'exil aux 590
ira un petit peu moins loin
néanmoins si vous avez une belle
batterie 4000 500 millions par heure
c'est un smartphone que vous pouvez
garder une journée et demie deux jours
en fonction de vos usages en fonction
fectivement aussi de la version c'est un
dragon exynos si vous y allez cool deux
jours vous allez y arriver si vous jouez
beaucoup et vous êtes tout le temps
dessus vous vous en douterez une journée
guère mieux ce que trouvent plutôt
agréable c'est d'avoir un bloc de charge
de 25 watts
si vous manquez un peu de batterie dans
la journée vous venez vous le branchez
vous laisser un quart d'heure vingt
minutes vous êtes reparti pour une
journée à peu près une journée ça reste
très rassurant si vous avez un bloc de
charge son fils
que ce soit pour le poser au travail ou
chez vous le soir pour recharger vous
pouvez vous avez de la recharge sans fil
15 watts est pas mal aussi
et puis le fait d'avoir la recharge
l'inversé ça peut être intéressant pour
vos samsung galaxy boys live notamment
pour venir les recharger si besoin une
petite recharge rapide une recherche
d'un point donc on voit très bien que ce
samsung galaxy s 20 fans edition et feu
vient vraiment faire la part belle au
jeu au gaming sur la version 5 j'ai
surtout de toute façon aujourd'hui si
vous avez acheté un smartphone 9 je vous
conseille d'aller acheter un smartphone
5 g il vous coûtera un peu plus cher
qu'un smartphone 4g
néanmoins il vous préparera pour
l'avenir parce que votre smartphone vous
allez garder au moins deux ans 2 ans
voit trois ans ce serait dommage
aujourd'hui d'acheter un smartphone qui
ne soit pas compatible 5 g alors que les
offres 5g vont arriver dans le grand
public en 2021 et vous allez pouvoir
bénéficier de collection beaucoup plus
rapide de latence beaucoup plus faible
et surtout de l'explosion du creloc
gaming sur smartphone donc ça serait
dommage de louper le coche et d'acheter
un smartphone uniquement 4g aujourd'hui
autre point que j'aime beaucoup c'est la
partie logicielle on tourne ici sur when
you lie deux basés sur un android 10
c'est très clair très lisible samsung a
très très très bien bossé que ce soit
pour les réglages de l'écran vous pouvez
passer sur intel sombre si vous le
souhaitez rester sur un thème clair vous
réglez très facilement les données
biométriques l'empreinte digitale que
vous paramétrez le bien-être numérique
les contrôles parentaux l'expérience
globale est très bien très lisible très
clair personnellement j'aime beaucoup et
pour tous les fans d'android là dessus
vous ne serez absolument pas déçu
autre point différenciant c'est la
partie photo et ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant je vous l'avais déjà dit
dans ma vidéo de découverte de ce
produit vous avez si un triptyque photo
vous allez avoir uniquement le
grand-angle et l'ultra grand temps
qu'ils resteront les mêmes existe
comment les mêmes que vous avez sur le
samsung galaxy s 20 ce qui va changer
ici c'est le téléobjectif le
téléobjectif ici on n'a pas de 64
mégapixels en 1 8 mégapixels qui ouvre f
2.4
on va donc venir forcément perdre en
qualité par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur le samsung galaxy s vingt
et une fois de plus il faut bien faire
des compromis on va pas tout avoir pour
un prix beaucoup moindre néanmoins vous
allez avoir un zoom optique x 3d pouvoir
monter jusqu'à space zoom x 30
on se regarde le résultat dans quelques
secondes tandis qu'à l'avant vous y
retrouver une caméra qui est planqué ici
c'est une 30 2 mégapixels un peu plus de
pixels que sur le samsung galaxy s 20 et
je vous montre le résultat une fois de
plus dans quelques instants
j'aime beaucoup le capteur principal le
rendu est vraiment très très très bien
hyper hyper qualitatif lorsque vous
passez son ultra grand-angle on le verra
déjà évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
sombre mais ça fait très bien son effet
il vous faut de la lumière vous vous en
douterez pouvais me retrouver ensuite
eh bien écoutez ça fait le taff très
très bien x 204 x 10 x 20 x 30 c'est ce
qu'on propose d'un point de vue logiciel
on se rapproche on s'approche on lisse
et on perd nos qualités mais vraiment
les photos avec votre cas pas principe
avec vos 12 mégapixels ça marche super
bien
la gestion des lumières est super les
ondes sont très très très bonne vraiment
j'aime beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
détails
l'ultra grand angle et plus brouillon
plus fous mais une fois de plus à du
très grand temps et on fait pas de la
magie à dessus des petits canards c'est
tout mignon on se rapproche on perd
forcément tout de suite en qualité en x
200 x 4 salissa toute sa liste des vous
venez zoomer davantage sa liste vous
avez un zoom optique x 3 idées vous
aller au delà
eh bien ça vient laisser cette
traitement logiciel et voyeur ce que
vous venez zoom est vraiment très très
loin jusqu'au x 30 la voilà c'est
inexploitable on peut le faire alors par
contre moi la caméra cette fille je suis
pas très fan il faut regarder au niveau
des po c'est lis énormément satire le 13
femmes sauf contraste je trouve c'est
pas génial j'ai un peu une bonne
macchabées là-dessus personnellement je
n'étais pas ça complètement dingue
qu'avaient avancé par une fois de plus
c'est très très bien regardez moi les
nuages c'est très précis très bien lu
traquant le temps bompas rond- journaux
ou non zoom et c'est flou au bout d'un
moment
mais malgré tout la qualité vraiment là
et on voit qu'on est dans l'adn d'un
photophone on est dans l'adn ici de la
gamme s 20 il faut pas chercher à venir
trozoul mais il faut rester sur le
basique sur les caméras principal
élément photos de nuit c'est super mots
il faisait nuit regardez ce que ça vous
sort alors luttera vantant les bons on
oublie on peut venir zoom et un tout
petit peu la nuit faut pas être trop
loin
regardez ça franchement c'est hyper
bluffant il faisait nuit on voit bien
les voitures le ciel les détails les
branches d'arbres ça marche vraiment
très très très bien et samsung a
vraiment très très très bien réussi sa
copie cette caméra principale
je les adore vous ne pourrez vous plaît
absolument aucune photo ça marchera pas
de toutes les façons
alors ici forcément il y aura des
compromis c'est pas du tout un
smartphone avec lequel elle pouvoir
filmer en 8k mais souhaitez vous filmer
en 8k aujourd'hui je vous le demande
dites le moi d'ailleurs en bas en
commentaire non je ne suis pas convaincu
je pense qu'aujourd'hui venir filmer en
8k avec un smartphone ça sert pas à
grand chose les constructeurs vous le
monde parce que c'est effectivement un
argument marketing ça permet de préparer
votre smartphone pour l'avenir mais
aujourd'hui les huit cas sur un
smartphone
bon si vous l'avez tant mieux si vous
l'avez pas c'est pas très grave
bien que le samsung galaxy s 20 f se
calque sur le samsung galaxy s vins
présentés début 2025 smartphones qui est
très actuel il a notamment du wifi 6 une
certification ip68 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière du nfc pour google paie
notamment du loup tous 5.0 et je vous le
dis je vous le redis une version 5 g
c'est la version que j'ai ici que je ne
peux que vous recommander d'ailleurs il
ya une différence de tarif entre la
version 4g la version 5 gym le sucre on
n'a pas tout appris tous marqués ici
rassurez-vous alors la version 4g en 128
go de stockage il vous coûtera 659 euros
et si vous voulez monter un petit peu
plus au niveau de vos stockage en 256 go
de stockage
il vous coûtera 7 129 euros maintenant
est ce qui m'intéresse moi le plus c'est
la version 5 g je pense que la version
avec 128 go de stockage est déjà très
très bonne d'autant plus que pouvaient
venir augmenter le stockage grâce à une
carte microsd pour monter jusqu'à 1 tera
il vous coûtera 759 euros et si vous
voulez vraiment ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui en termes de stockage ici
dans mon temps en 256 giga et bien il
vous coûtera 829 euros et une fois de
plus si vous intéresse vous aimez les
liens en bas dans la description perso
ça smartphones que j'ai beaucoup d'eux
par le format de par la qualité de
l'écran de par sa polyvalence en photo
il ne va pas aussi loin que le samsung
galaxy s 20 néanmoins le prix n'est pas
non plus même
même si c'est un smartphone qui est
sorti mi 2020 et qui est l'évolution de
nos smartphones sortie des bus
il vint il reste très actuel fin 2020 et
même début 2021 je trouve très
intéressant l'évolution de la gamme s en
2020 en partant du s 20 jusqu'aux 20
ultra avec la déclinaison s20 et feu
personnellement je suis conquise vous
permet d'avoir un smartphone de la gamme
s 20 à moindre coût avec des compromis
certes mais aucun compromis effet là
dessus en terme de performance et en
termes de qualité photo sur notre
objectif principal
a vous de me dire vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez en bas un commentaire
comme en ont trouvé samsung galaxy s 20
et feu s'il vous intéresse qu est ce que
vous pourriez en faire pourtant photos
plutôt multimédia plutôt gaming
productivité pourquoi pas marquer moi
tout ça en bas en commentaire et
campagne on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech m'ont beaucoup
d'amoureux des gros bisous à très vite
[Musique]